[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Florida America's droopy dick
this Florida episode is crazy personal
to me it's like you know personal it is
and my grandma passed away last year and
we went to her actual condo in Florida
that is the condo community that I grew
up going to every year it was like this
camp trip my parents came down and
stayed in the condo everybody like used
our bathroom it might my grandma
Harriet's apartment my first day of
directing I directed for ran Direction
Susie Essman and La quasar my brother it
was really really special
can't believe I'm pumping my mother
we had ver last state planned and it was
just gonna be Cadillac footage we got
like one shot with this caddy and then
it broke not even in the middle like
almost immediately after we started
shooting us driving it was a little
panicky for a second first you're like
I'm going to punch myself in the face
that this one improv that we need broke
down this is her last day in Florida we
like huddled up and we came up with this
like groceries walk I'm so happy that
that happened because I think it added
to that montage absolutely sometimes
those things lead to the best thing so
it was definitely did
[Music]